وينضم الينا من عمان مدير مكتب الجزيره
حسن
الشوبكي نعم زين العابدين يعني اغلب
الهتافات التي ظهرت هنا منذ نحو ربع ساعه
بعد ان بدات هذه المسيره تطالب بالحفاظ
على حق العوده وتقول نعم لحق العوده وتقول
لا لتقويض الاونور وكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين وان مخططات التوجع
التجويع
والتهجير
صوتك عالي صوتك واضح بحنا جركم النبيله
بدنا نسمع صوت الشعب الاردني وعلا يا
بلادي علا يا بلادي ع وعلا يا بلادي علا ع
يا بلادي ع الموت ولا المذله الموت وذ
الموت نعم زين العابدين يعني كما تسمعون
الفات لتقويض الانور وان هذا التجويع
ومخططات التجويع والتهجير التي تنفذها
اسرائيل لن تتم وهنالك ايضا مطالبات من
الشعب الاردني بان يتم فتح كل الطرق
للمساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه
للشعب الفلسطيني في غزه والكانت يعني
الجماهير الاردنيه ومن خلال التظاهر اول
امس امام
يعني المقر الاونور و في عمان كانت طالبت
ان لا يجب ان يكون هنالك استهداف لهذه
الوكاله التي تقوم بدور كبير الملايين
الذين تؤويهم في الدول التي تؤوي اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين فمثل هذا العمل تقويض عمل
نوروا قد يعني يتسبب بمخاطر كبيره اذ ان
يعني الاونور لها دور كبير في غزه وكذلك
دور كبير في الدول التي تؤوي اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين وفي مقدمتها الاردن لذلك
المطلب الرئيسي اليوم نعم ان لا يتم تقويض
النور التي هي يعني العمود الفقري ل بقاء
الفلسطينيين وعودتهم الى بلاد